et notre invité ce matin c'est
Jean-Pierre Raffarin bonjour Merci
beaucoup bonjour à tous Jean-Pierre
Raffarin ancien Premier ministre
président de l'ONG leader pour la paix
et auteur de ce livre on va le revoir ne
sortons pas de l'histoire c'est aux
éditions Michel Lafond on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a donc commémoré
le 8 mai hier une remontée des
Champs-Élysées des airs et un discours
en hommage à Jean Moulin et à la
Résistance française à Lyon Lyon ou les
manifestants ont été soigneusement tenu
à l'écart est-ce que le chef de l'État
est coupé des Français isolés
faut pas exagérer les choses nous sommes
aujourd'hui le 9 mai j'en ai de l'Europe
hier c'était la journée de l'armistice
j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir une réunion
de travail avec les leaders pour la paix
puisque c'est notre assemblée donc une
quarantaine de personnalités on a
travaillé avec le président de la
République il était extraordinairement
impliqué sur toutes les questions
internationales connaissant très bien
les questions si difficiles que
l'Arménie le Liban évidemment l'Ukraine
et tension entre la Chine et les
États-Unis la question africaine quand
on voit la situation dans laquelle est
le monde et qu'on voit le présent comme
il est impliqué on dit qu'il est quand
même assez pilote de la situation et je
crois que toute cette campagne qui
consiste à le faire responsable de tout
c'est probablement très exagéré et
finalement vous voyez qu'un certain
nombre de Français aujourd'hui sont un
peu lassés de ces agitations quand vous
voyez les jeunes au lycée de Saintes
comme ils accueillent le président de la
République quand vous voyez le 1er mai
certes il y a beaucoup de monde dans les
rues mais il y a beaucoup de monde aussi
sur les plages et que le soleil il y a
beaucoup de monde qui qui vit la vie de
famille que vivent tous les Français
donc ne voyons pas
je dis que
tu es minoritaire majoritaire ça ne veut
rien dire il y a quelles élections qui
disent ça donc pour le moment on a une
majorité relative à l'Assemblée donc ce
que je crois c'est que avoir tout au
travers du président de la République et
en faire le seul responsable de toutes
les difficultés je pense que c'est
exagéré et je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de Français qui pensent que cet exagéré
aujourd'hui il y a eu une crise on a eu
un covid on a quand même on a une
situation de guerre on a une situation à
nos portes il y a quand même d'un
certain nombre de responsabilités tout
ça ce n'est pas Macron Macron c'est pas
le covid Macron c'est pas l'Ukraine
Macron c'est pas l'inflation Macron
c'est pas toutes les difficultés que
nous avons aujourd'hui sur lesquels il
faut faire face sont pas des crise
sociale que connaît le pays suite à la
réforme des retraites c'est pas Emmanuel
Macron non plus je pense que la question
des retraites a toujours mis du monde
dans la rue j'ai fait une réforme en
2003 il y avait beaucoup de monde dans
la rue donc c'est quelque chose d'assez
historique et donc je ne pense pas que
Monsieur Macron soit responsable de
toutes nos difficultés
dans notre pays n'a pas eu des erreurs
n'a pas fait des erreurs en dirigeant le
pays souvenez-vous de toutes nos
agitations qu'on a pu avoir et j'en ai
vu du monde dans les rues et donc il
faut pas exagérer quand vous regardez
les choses que ce soit que Jacques
Chirac soit Lionel Jospin que ce soit
avec Nicolas Sarkozy avec François
Hollande il y a eu des agitations très
très fortes bon mais vous parlez
d'agitation vous avez employé le mot de
campagne contre le chef de l'État qui
fait campagne est-ce que est-ce que face
à lui il y a une machine aussi politique
médiatique qui s'est développée je pense
sentiment je pense que en effet les deux
groupes politiques extrémistes que ce
soit une UPS ou le rassemblement
national ont réussi à focaliser un peu
le débat politique de c'est un effet
loupe de ce point de vue là je pense
qu'il y a des erreurs du côté de la
majorité je pense que le parti politique
de la majorité n'est pas suffisamment
puissant quand je compare la réforme des
retraites quand moi j'ai fait avec l'UMP
la réforme des retrait de 2003 nous
avions un délégué par circonscription
qui gérait les retraites qui étaient
coachées par Xavier Bertrand par
François Baroin quelques autres au
niveau national
je pense que il y avait une machine
politique avec un certain nombre de
leaders je crois vraiment qu'on peut
gagner une élection présidentielle sans
parti simplement parce que les
circonstances font qu'on vous êtes la
personne de la situation absolument mais
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse gouverner
sans parti parce qu'on a besoin de
ressources humaines parce qu'on a besoin
d'implantation on a besoin de renouveler
les cadres on a besoin de de dynamique
là je pense que aujourd'hui
grosso modo le terrain de la majorité et
pas suffisamment
occupé et un pari comment il peut faire
ça protège un peu le président or là le
président est très exposé et au fond il
est assez peu protégé il a peu de
leaders politiques qui sont très très
connus on a fait du temps de Chirac il y
avait des baladures il y avait des
Pasqua il un certain nombre de
personnalités qui d'une certaine manière
protéger le président là on a un
président qui est surexposé alors il y
contribue lui-même en étant très très
présent mais globalement
ni son gouvernement ni son parti ne sont
suffisamment puissants pour le protéger
c'est une erreur pour vous je pense que
on ne peut pas gouverner ce pays sans un
parti politique sans une puissance
d'organisation capable de participer au
débat et je crois que s'il y a cet effet
loupe dont vous parlez je crois que cet
effet loupe il est en grande partie du
aussi au fait que la majorité n'a pas la
puissance nécessaire et que les
oppositions sont hyper puissantes et
hyper présentes il y a une bascule à un
moment dans le mouvement le fait que le
les revendications les slogans ce sont
ce sont focalisés sur le président de la
République sur sa personne lui-même par
exemple et des militants de la CGT des
membres de la France insoumise comme
manifesté devant le siège de Renaissance
au cri de Louis XVI on a décapité Macron
on peut recommencer qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire
toute la logique de Mélenchon on voit
bien que Mélenchon a joué cette
thématique là de la Révolution et donc
il prend les exemples historiques donc
on voit bien que Mélenchon se positionne
en leader de l'opposition et pour ça il
a besoin qu'on focalise sur Macron parce
qu'il en fait l'adversaire parce qu'au
fond c'est la place qui l'intéresse et
ça prend ou pas est-ce que c'est un
discours qui fait tâche d'huile selon
vous je ne suis pas sûr si vous voulez
la présence et l'impact c'est deux
choses différentes si la présence
militante de la gauche aujourd'hui
l'extrême gauche est très très forte
c'est pas pour ça que ça forcement
beaucoup d'impact sur les gens mais ça
occupe les médias ça ça occupe la scène
et donc ça ça fait en sorte que le
président est toujours sur la sellette
et je trouve que il n'est pas
suffisamment protégé aujourd'hui par un
parti politique ou par des leaders
politiques qui
occupent la scène à côté de lui alors
justement politiquement comment on en
sort est-ce que Gérard Larcher à
Matignon c'est la bonne sortie de crise
je crois que le président Larcher a déjà
répondu à cette question lui-même donc
et il a évidemment les qualités pour
faire ça est-ce que les circonstances
politiques seraient
compatible avec
ses souhaits et la logique c'est la
toriale ça c'est une autre affaire en
tout état causes le 6 ça devait se faire
un jour ça ne se ferait pas avant les
sénatoriales de mon point de vue parce
que laisser la toriales mobilise le
Sénat sont des élections très
importantes ce sont des élections qui en
général se font contre Paris avec ce
font naturellement contre le pouvoir
central très souvent et donc elle est
allée au gouvernement maintenant ce
serait quelque chose qui pour euh
je pense que je pense qu'en le président
du Sénat dit il faut des élections pour
construire quelque chose laisser
natoriales arrive peut-être qu'après les
sénatoriales sera possible de faire
quelque chose je n'en sais strictement
rien et là
après les sénatoriales il faut un
républicain Matignon moi j'espère que il
y aura un accord possible je ne sais si
ce sera faisable mais si vous voulez moi
j'ai grand peur de l'arrivée de Madame
Le Pen et nous avons quatre ans devant
nous si pendant quatre ans il n'y a pas
de réforme possible s'il y a pas de
dynamique gouvernementale s'il n'y a pas
une action qui entraîne les Français
naturellement nous allons directement à
une élection de Madame Le Pen donc je
pense qu'il faut essayer un moment ou un
autre de construire une majorité il y a
une majorité dans ce pays avec les
républicain c'est une majorité de centre
droit il y a une majorité du centre
peut-être un peu de centre gauche mais
tu sens tout droit si on avait un
programme grosso modo par rapport au
regard des les programmes des uns ou des
autres on trouvera assez vite un
consensus au cœur même de l'Assemblée
nationale pour avoir une majorité donc
les choses me paraissent accessibles
alors il y a des crispations je ne sais
pas ça peut pas se faire avant des
élections comme les élections
sanatoriales après ça pourrait se faire
en tout cas
parce qu'il faut un programme il faut un
projet il faut du fond que doit faire le
chef de l'État qu'est-ce qu'il doit dire
aux républicain je pense que il faut
parler action donc
est-ce qu'on fait une grande loi sur la
décentralisation je trouve absurde qu'on
puisse pas avoir de mer à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat donc il faut des
députés mères il faut des sénateurs
maires je crois qu'il faudrait que on
revienne à des élections législatives en
cours de quinquennat donc un mandat de 4
ans de députés ou des élections comme
aux États-Unis de mitter donc une
respiration législative dans le
quinquennat il y a un certain nombre de
réformes de cette nature à pouvoir
pousser donc je pense que l'expérience
c'est la toriale et là si les sénateurs
étaient
engagés dans un processus d'action il
serait capable de bâtir une une loi qui
donnerait un nouveau souple à la
décentraîners ce qui permettrait
peut-être de désexposer un peu le
président parce que s'il est territoires
étaient plus présents dans la classe des
responsabilités il y aurait moins cette
centralisation du débat politique donc
je crois que là il y a quelque chose à
faire il y a le texte sur l'immigration
qui reste qui reste à faire aujourd'hui
donc il y a un certain nombre de sujets
ça a été une faute de le reporter pour
vous c'était le président
constate sa majorité il a pas il a pas
de possibilité donc il retire le texte
pour le moment mais si on pouvait créer
une majorité sur un texte je pense qu'il
faut faire quelque chose sur
l'immigration aujourd'hui on a laissé
déraper l'immigration l'immigration
c'était un sujet majeur il faut pouvoir
faire un texte sur ce sujet et ça
peut-être que les républicains sont en
mesure de le faire donc il y a un
certain nombre Macron c'est une sorte en
même temps les républicains ils veulent
pas de la du titre du séjour
majorité et il faut de toute façon
discuter avec les républicains et
prendre un certain nombre de leurs idées
il y a pas de majorité sans partage d'un
programme mais je pense que ce que les
choses sont faisa parce que on peut
avoir un contrat de 2 ans on n'est pas
obligé d'aller jusqu'à la fin du 20 donc
si ils veulent reprendre en liberté pas
peut-être reprendre en probabilité si on
leur donne la possibilité d'avoir un
texte ou de texte je ne sais pas
simplement pour dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui il y a sans
doute une majorité au Parlement pour peu
qu'on trouve le programme adapté à la
majorité avant de passer aux questions
internationales nous sommes le 9 mai
c'est la Journée de l'Europe il y a une
proposition de loi à l'Assemblée qui
sera déposée dans le cadre de la niche
de renaissance pour rendre obligatoire
le drapeau européen à côté du drapeau
français au fronton des mairies est-ce
que vous en pensez vous y êtes vous êtes
pour ou contre oh je suis plutôt pour je
pense que je me souviens on avait eu ce
débat au Sénat ça avait été toute une
histoire tout un débat quand on avait
mis toute une histoire en France parce
que le on a le sentiment que mettre le
drapeau européen c'est un peu effacé
l'autre drapeau donc vous souvenez une
paire de souveraineté ce serait une
paire de souveraineté en tout cas c'est
un symbole le drapeau français le
symbole de notre unité nationale et donc
mettre le temps pour européen à côté ça
ça irrite un certain nombre de gens moi
ça ne me gêne pas du tout puisque je
suis profondément européen je cherche à
faire en sorte qu'en permanence ces deux
ambitions sont compatibles être fier
d'être français d'être attaché à nos
racines à notre culture à notre langue
et faire en sorte que nous soyons
européens et que c'est le rapport de
force mondiale dans ce monde le retour
des puissances d'État que sont les
grands pays aujourd'hui qui gouverne le
monde je pense que l'Europe est une
nécessité
quelque peu réticent disons que c'est
pas le moment c'est pas opportun que
c'est loin de préoccupations des
Français
c'est loin du préoccupations des
Français mais c'est pas on n'est pas
obligé d'être toujours mobilisé sur la
première préoccupation des Français nous
sommes européens qui est un parti
européen non ça ne me surprend pas dans
une majorité il faut toujours un peu
faire des différences et donc tant qu'à
faire des différences autant les faire
sur des sujets qui sont pas prioritaires
donc
je pense que ça fait partie des
dynamiques partisanes un dernier mot
justement pour terminer sur ce qui se
passe à l'Assemblée on en revient un peu
aux républicains mais il y aura lapl du
groupe lot la proposition là le groupe
liote qui vise à abroger la retraite à
64 ans qui sa examinait le 8 juin et des
républicains ont annoncé qu'ils allaient
la voter est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle
peut passer et est-ce que vous comprenez
la position de ces républicains dont
elle est en pratique non je ne comprends
pas bien cette position puisque au fond
dans la doctrine du parti républicain
historique
depuis l'UMP on avait toujours envisagé
la réforme des retraites comme une
continuité de l'action gouvernementale
monsieur Balladur a fait une réforme
j'ai fait une réforme Nicolas Sarkozy a
fait une réforme il y a tout on a fait
les uns et les autres un certain nombre
d'étapes je crois que d'ailleurs c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire les réformes
faut pas faire la réforme du grand soir
on va tout essayer de régler son on voit
que la réforme à point de la retraite à
point n'a pas pu passer parce qu'elle
était trop globale donc je pense que il
faut faire ça par étape et je trouve que
les républicains faisaient partie de
ceux qui construisaient cette réforme
des retraites par étape et donc faire
machine arrière sur ce sujet je trouve
que c'est un opportunisme douteux on va
parler des questions internationales et
l'Ukraine oui
cette journée de célébration de l'union
européenne est-ce que le comment est-ce
que vous voyez le l'importance du
message pour vous
ah je crois qu'il est très important de
de soutenir l'Ukraine dans cette affaire
parce que cette agression russe est une
tragédie pour le peuple
ukrainien il a besoin ce peuple qu'on le
soutienne donc je crois qu'il y a pas
d'ambiguïté et c'est le rôle de la
Commission européenne d'exprimer cette
solidarité avec l'Ukraine ce qui me
préoccupe c'est que je crains que cette
guerre soit longue et si cette guerre
est longue la deuxième victime après le
peuple
ukrainien la deuxième victime sera
peut-être l'Union européenne et je
trouve que c'est un sujet quand même qui
est très très préoccupant je trouve que
il y a dans cette une guerre en Ukraine
des conséquences d'abord sur nos
économies la conséquences sur
l'inflation les conséquences sur la
crise de l'énergie qui crée sa tension
et puis il y a cette question de la
défense de la souveraineté européenne et
on voit des divergences y compris entre
Français et Allemands aujourd'hui où on
voit que finalement il y a trois ans le
temps était en mort cérébrale disait-on
et aujourd'hui tous les pays se pressent
pour être membre de l'OTAN et on est en
guerre en Europe et le chef de guerre
sont les Américains donc la question
fondamentale c'est notre souveraineté
c'est notre capacité à nous-mêmes donner
à cette Europe une capacité de nous
protéger nous-mêmes et donc on voit bien
qu'il y a ceux qui voient notre ami au
travers de la défense des Américains et
ceux qui voient notre avenir aussi avec
notre propre défense et donc ça nous met
en cause je crois qu'après le covid on
avait eu cette aspiration forte d'avoir
une souveraineté européenne pour nous
protéger contre en l'occurrence les
pandémies mais de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une sorte de conscience européenne
pour nous protéger et on allait à la
défense européenne on allait verser ça
du président de la République il est il
est isolé aujourd'hui en Europe il est
suivi ou pas et bien écoutez je pense
que plus on est proche de la frontière
avec la Russie plus les gens sont
pro-américains plus on s'en éloigne plus
il y a d'un peu de distance et plus il y
a un besoin
quand
absolument parce que quand les peuples
européens ont peur de la guerre ils
appellent les États-Unis
ça d'accord Lancaster House qui nous
permettait d'avoir une défense
européenne qui était une défense
française principalement avec une
défense du Royaume-Uni qui était
articulée qui fait que quand un
sous-marin russe était dans nos eaux
territoriales de navire un français à
l'anglais raccompagné très vite et le
russe ne résistait pas donc il y avait
c'est une puissance maintenant on voit
que ceci est terminé parce que
naturellement le Royaume-Uni est dans le
bloc avec les Américains donc on a des
fragilités là qui parce qu'on a une
action qui est un peu paralysée puisque
il y a plus cette dynamique pour une
défense européenne maintenant de
beaucoup de gens pensent que le soutien
des américains est suffisant alors
justement dans ce contexte le ministre
des Affaires étrangères chinois et en
Europe en France en Allemagne en Norvège
quel sens il faut voir à cette visite
est-ce qu'il y a une volonté de se
rapprocher de l'Union européenne dans un
contexte de tension avec les États-Unis
et est-ce que c'est forcément une bonne
nouvelle pour l'Union européenne je
pense que il est clair que les chinois
sont préoccupés de voir cette
autonisation de l'Europe donc ils vont
venir je pense pour plaider à une
indépendance de l'Europe donc ça c'est
clair que c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour les Chinois d'abord de voir
l'Europe se rapprocher d'être comme ça
des États-Unis donc je pense que c'est
ça leur propre objectif mais nous nous
pensons que ce qui est très important
c'est qu'il fasse pression sur Poutine
pour le cesser le feu et donc nous avons
cette dialectique là que nous pouvons
aujourd'hui
proposer à la Chine de jouer un rôle si
elle veut vraiment s'affirmer comme un
pays qui défend la paix de faire
pression sur elle a les moyens de faire
pression sur Poutine pour qu'on puisse
aller vers le fond ça peut être que le
médiateur ça peut être que la Chine qui
peut
mettre je pense que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans des situations où ce
sont les les alliés des gens qui ont le
plus de poids ce sont pas les
adversaires donc nous ne sommes pas dans
le camp de la Russie donc on a assez peu
de poids sur la Russie je pense que ceux
qui sont proches de la Russie comme
l'Inde ou comme la Chine peuvent avoir
du poids pour faire pression sur Poutine
pour aller au cesser le feu quelle
serait l'intérêt de la Chine en
l'occurrence si Snatch ce se rapprocher
des européens ou acquérir une stature
internationale qui a qu'elle a déjà je
pense que la Chine comme les États-Unis
et tous les deux sont un peu en ce qu'on
appelle l'hystérie de guerre c'est une
guerre morale qui dit ça je pense que
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
vrai qu'on est dans une forme d'hystérie
de l'un contre l'autre une sorte
d'obsession politique des Chinois pour
les États-Unis les États-Unis pour les
Chinois et dans cette dans ce
dialectique là il est clair que
une Europe indépendante un portrait une
respiration et un équilibre donc je
pense que vraiment le dokran danger pour
les États-Unis comme pour la Chine c'est
de voir un moment l'Europe
il serait plus la force d'équilibre
qu'elle peut être non seulement pour le
débat entre les États-Unis et la Chine
mais aussi pour gérer les questions
africaines qui sont des questions de
plus en plus difficiles on voit que la
guerre en Ukraine s'exporte un peu avec
Wagner en Afrique et on voit bien que on
a besoin d'impôts européen pour
l'équilibre du monde et ça je pense que
c'est l'intérêt et des États-Unis et de
la Chine aussi et justement aujourd'hui
il y a un débat à l'Assemblée autour de
Wagner un texte d'un député Renaissance
qui demande que Wagner soit inscrite sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
de l'Union européenne est-ce que vous y
êtes favorable est-ce que vous pensez
que ce sera voté à l'assemblée à
uneanimité je ne sais pas je pense que
il est clair que les méthodes qui sont
employés par Wagner sont des méthodes
qui relèvent
d'attitude qui ont des proximité avec le
terroriste mais les choses sont très
compliquées dans la mesure où dans un
certain nombre de pays par exemple en
Afrique ou Wagner intervient avec des
autorités d'État donc avec une
légitimité de l'État donc à ce moment-là
on a quand on est l'état on est plus
terroriste donc il y a un certain nombre
de sens favorable c'est un sujet c'est
un sujet très compliqué on ne peut pas
très traiter si facilement que ça quand
vous voyez un état qui appelle Wagner
pour sa propre protection sa propre
sécurité Wagner à ce moment-là est dans
une position de responsable d'État donc
vous voyez c'est quelque chose de
d'assez difficile à traiter il est clair
que pour nous Wagner est un adversaire
redoutable et qui a des méthodes qui
sont proches de du méthodes de
terroristes une dernière question
Jean-Philippe Tanguy député
rassemblement national dimanche sur LCI
a dit qu'il aurait souhaité vous
additionner sur vos liens avec la Chine
dans la commission d'enquête qui préside
sur les ingérences étrangères comment
est-ce que vous avez pris ce type de
déclaration je pense qu'il est pas bien
informé de des choses donc tout ceci
mais tout à fait
je dirais pas indifférent mais je je
mesure que il y a des informations qui
ont faciles à donner et j'ai une
responsabilité puisque j'ai été en
charge d'une mission du ministre des
Affaires étrangères pour les relations
avec les entreprises et pour aider les
entreprises à aller sur le marché
chinois donc ceci est terminé maintenant
donc j'ai eu cette mission et donc
pendant cette mission j'ai aidé les
entreprises françaises à entrer en Chine
donc pas ma mission était cadrée c'est
une mission bénévole c'est une mission
qui était son responsabilité avec un
rapport permanent que je faisais au
ministre donc j'étais dans une position
officielle dans ce que je faisais
c'était toujours en ligne avec la
diplomatie donc ma mission c'est pas une
mission personnelle c'était une mission
d'État avec une logique d'État dans les
intérêts de l'État en passant par les
intérêts de nos entreprises
vous en avez un petit parler c'est la
conférence annuelle de votre ONG un
leader pour la paix en ce moment
aujourd'hui il y aura une assemblée
plénière au Sénat hier vous le disiez
vous avez été reçu par Emmanuel Macron à
l'Élysée quel message avez-vous envie de
faire passer
faisons très attention aujourd'hui à
cette hystérie de guerre c'était état
d'esprit belliqueux qui existe
naturellement dans les pays en guerre ou
finalement il y a une criminalisation de
la guerre de plus en plus et il y a
cette globalisation de la haine ce qui
est préoccupant c'est que des pays qui
ne sont pas aujourd'hui en guerre
développe aussi cette violence il y a
une sorte de proximité entre la guerre
et la et la violence que nous savons
dans nos sociétés je pense que la
violence et la guerre sont des sœurs
jumelles et au fond il y a un climat
général dans le monde aujourd'hui qui
prépare d'une certaine manière la guerre
c'est pour ça que notre ONG a créé une
école itinérante de la paix il y a des
écoles de guerre partout il n'y a pas
d'école de paix la paix c'est quelque
chose qui s'apprend c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit travailler la diplomatie les
relations internationales qu'on
travaille avec le la au Vatican sur
qu’est-ce que c’est que la dignité de
quelqu’un souvent la violence c'est
quand quelqu'un s'est est attaqué dans
sa dignité donc je pense que là il y a
un travail très important et c'est pour
ça que nous avons construit cette école
de la paix qui va dans tous les pays où
il y a des demandes pour essayer de
développer cette culture de la paix dont
on a besoin c'est cette pédagogie de la
paix qui est une bonne réponse à cette
hystérie de guerre
et absolument aujourd'hui avec Nicolas
Sarkozy notamment mais aussi Hubert
merci Jean-Pierre Raffarin d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin
c'est à la Une de
votre merci
Stéphane passe au club des territoires